well we are in this nursery but
in 2003 Bogota edition we started this
third day the day of the award the
day of integration but the day in
where you already know the winner of this
2013 edition here in bogotá really
we are very happy and have already traveled
all this journey through Latin America and
of being here of course in company
of the entire Colombian ecosystem
really enjoying
all this technological arena this
dynamism of course of the
developers here in bogotá really
today we have a lot of information for
share with you we are going to start
technically speaking of the integration
let's talk about the high page
let's also see the state of the
groups as they have spent the night and how
come the applications those solutions
that we had yesterday
presentation that really are very
interesting and propose a scenario
very good technical of course also
business unit and very innovative
also so I'm going to introduce a colleague
and friend paco how are you good morning
yes well and that here without sleeping like
all here
all working without stopping now what
we had surely warned that night
they did not sleep and I think that was the way
of the teams were giving him all
the night and being here present
exactly everything for exactly
exactly really and very good what
we have seen they have been very involved
with each of the projects and have
developed solutions really very
interesting successes very good days like
is
good morning or how are you happy
be on the final day I want to know
who will win who will win a lot
much much nervousness of course
see but of course we have all that
motivation to move forward we have
seen very interesting solutions like
I commented to them and really the
developers are still very concentrated
the designers are giving the touch-ups
final the business strategist and
defining the last points of the
presentation also that comes in the
afternoon and in the afternoon we will have
course the presence of all
juries that accompany us here in the
ecosystem of colombia study of probos
2003 in this edition here that we are
living together with you so
it really is very interesting what
that we have seen here so how do you
commented we are going to
start our day with the stage
technical let's see prediction in day and
let's see a little bit of maps version
13 for javascript and let's see also
some little things with the flashes of
klaus thorax we follow of course
refining each of the applications and
as Paco said also the groups do not
have rested 'not the night have
rested but they have not stopped
work of course in the presentation
to the dream face that there are many faces
of good sleep but here they took a
red and quickly the
groups so the belo red but by
course the red the developers and for
you're connected there to say
what is a red or a red in a cafe
here typical in colombia because good
how do you know if we are going through all
Latin America we started for good
aires would be one per city of mexico
We are here in Bogota and in Buenos Aires
as you know red is a wine
there is a coffee we would not sleep with that
Colombian color and now we continue until
sao paulo ni of course continues in
san pablo- we continue developing
open source applications open for
the regional SMEs are
contributions of money but you and
google for this tremendous community of
Latin American developers so
we prepare ourselves we concentrate
the groups I will move towards the groups
asking sorry do we have there camera
talking spy we're going to send a little
let's trust a little
vote out there
but it does not take advantage to do promotion
how the spy camera is used too
so he's touring the groups like this
that you are connected there that
you want to see much more than what happens
in minute by minute his successes if he
I suggest that you join the community of
developers I suggest if you forget
of course the developer pei
google minute minutes of everything that goes
happening here in this book but you
2013 Bogota and of course the connection
permanent community to you that
you are connected there you can participate with
we can solve the challenges
you can comment and you can choose where
is where the camera can be is
change to the day so good concentric
we warm up engines we prepare for
the technical challenge that already comes too
we have virtual mentors and mentors
throughout the day so
we heat engines and come back with a lot
more level or but bosch 2013 edition
bogotá we already smell
william lion of the angel business group
we go more or less to 20% of the back end
because we are learning python as
crazy and I think there's no in the group
we are all simply very good at what
what are we doing and joining forces
here to finish fast
guillermo gómez the group 7 we are
40 percent but we have the surprise
it changes every morning and we all have all
contributed many important things in the
group but I rescued our
partner who has a lot of knowledge and
it does not help contributed too much more
thank you
good afternoon no man is july
César a Erazo I am part of the group
recycle then we take an approximate
75 percent of the project and then
we consider our genius
It has always been our own manager
who was he
who originated the idea good my name
is Ricardo Chiriboga from the group of
agronomy
It seems to me that the one who has given the most
size in the group has been between
designer and the project because they have
tried to guide us on the
idea my friend
Didier is taking care of the part
of the front end and the staff in submitting it
on average by 40 percent we
lack to expose the services to en point
so that front-end person with his
ah
well good we continue in this developers
2013 to you who are there to you who are
there of course because finally you
we talk about 6 connected with us
in this virtual audience with a lot
adrenaline of development really what
we are enjoying a lot of good
let's talk a little yes because
we talk about the spy camera and your
successes I tell you if already people
wants to see says I want to see the camera
spy in gloves so the spy camera
of the bus is for three others
André to you who is requesting it
is moving the spy camera since you
we show going to the group wanted to
with we have more messages and assembling picón
also and from the camera that goes if the
you see
well there we see the camera to see if it goes
for the team we have the spy camera to
see if it moves if you move the camera goes
being out there look how that camera is going
spy
tremendous how the good camera goes the
camera follows of course traveling
the groups were left as was
asking we started our approach
technical but puerto rico's message
several because lopez following us from
puerto rico says that camera so
came out spy
these days all puerto rico
sticking the footprint by sticking the footprint
in a new message that incorporates the
developer vos of course of all
Latin America connected there is wanted
and what stamina looks how perfect is
spy camera continues to travel and
we are going to go
technologically this technical approach
of today very quickly we are going to
introduce we do not have to converse a
little google maps
we are going to present prediction and foot and the
idea is that you who are there connected
of course and each teams
can use all the suites of
space that Google proposes on the day of
yesterday and in the first of our days
here in bogota
we were also presenting the console
of display you know you have to be
connected that there are lots of
options and by
the groups are also using
good one of today's ideas central
is to use prediction and skin
Prediction option is very interesting in
this case prediction is the solution that
proposes the representation of networks
neuronal between the good and in what
I can justly call to make use of
a neural network oriented to services and
we do not want to roughly name any
way if this service is very
interesting supports two models
mathematicians as we always do
of categorization and that's very
interesting because it allows
permanently in the solutions
computer or in solutions in
overall we have to categorize
things do it in an intelligent way
somehow it is that it is very
interesting to cross from levels in
the applications then why
we invite you to use prediction and for
that we're going to show you that you're there
connected how to do it if not only
is categorization but we also have
the possibility of regression
numerical another mathematical model very
interesting that is usually associated or
you can understand more when we speak
of temperatures when we load a year
two or whatever amount of time
period and based on that model of
numbers and that we have the numerical model
we can predict what temperatures
could happen tomorrow or
anyone
and on the basis of all that knowledge
we can make decisions
correct and that is one of the ideas of
predictions and pious and then I ask you
Your successes that accompany me here and
we are going to go then very
quickly if this scenario where
we can use or where we can see
while the camera is already making the camera
is the ceiling stopped
an apple and in google colombia me
I feel hopefully murdered but clear
the camera the fia shows us the
messages that really is that happy
that I'm with that camera traveling like this
ok let's go to the console then cloud
punto.com I will use the console
new bar with sun there we have all
the spice one and foot and more expression and
foot and so we have to have in
account that we have to generate a
project as we did also at
long of these two days inside is the
active project the gateway you need
use in the project and in this case
It is very important because to start
use prediction in version 16 and
I need the name of the project the number
of project previously in the other
it could not be freely so much
more ordered and to version 1.6 of
prediction that is the one that we are going to use
now we have then the side page
we are going to have to authorize us
again we go back to the open model
authentication so we have to
authorize and based on that we will load
information and that information that box
of information goes with that little box we're going to
train a model that model is the one
we are going to make inquiries
to always use the example of
languages ​​and I'll show you how
integrate with python two models one
based on language detection and other
of course based on feelings
of the people we are going to make a book of
visits that is used for example in
hotels that can be used to
public services for example if the bus
success brings agents the agent then
delivered a feedback yes it's always good
well, then let's do
queries to see automatically from
smarter way based on what
write people let's say this is
written in English in French or in
Spanish
people from different countries
I am international installation and
then based on that after we passed
from that review we're going to ask a
model that is already distressed in google
following the prediction that is already
available so that any lights that
does not lie down if it is zero if for
consult the sentiment be google has
left in this great neural network
amount of information to detect if
I'm not giving good feedback a
positive feedback a neutral feedback
negative negative feedback to that I do not wear it
more be good I need to see
but here in Colombia they will be very
good then automatically
consulting the two models
first to the model that we are going to load
us to detect the language and
second the google funded model
let's determine automatically
in a much smarter way our
visit book and let's color yes
with red and green colors each
the comments that people make
it seems you need it seems spectacular
at the same time then in this first model
this first bit of development
let's do
let's try the model of the model
language detection this player to
our based on a text file of
406 lines only
he came with me
Here we have how we make try the
skins in general is usually used the
tail and foot explorer yes to not make a
full development I'm just going to
try with parameters from this console
and that way already detect to see if
I'm doing the model correctly
notice that I am showing you here
the ipi explorer gluttony I will recharge the
page both the services we are going to
look for prediction I had around here
version 1.6 of prediction notice that
I have all the methods that I can
access I have the difference that has
what to keep in mind is that I can do
a prediction based on models
which are the costed model in
the one that is made available google and
google prediction so you consume them
is massive and the other models are the
that I can charge look I'm going to
list these models this will fail in
first moment if this is going to fail
because I need to authorize me how they see
up here but we're going to make it fail
so that you also understand that
it is very important that they ask me first
what project to which project do I have
to consult then let's go to
look for our console I told them that
We are working on the project theme
It must be an adverb note here
I have the project number once
have this project number I'm going to paste
here and I'll tell you list me all the
models that have effectively fail
because he's saying that I'm not
authorized to create ok then let's
authorize us
notice that I only need
handle the data as well as permission of the
four permissions that I can have
available I authorize I do the
execution and here is already showing me
that I have two models one of the model that
it's called mexico and mx we're going to create the
model of Bogota but of course this takes
a few seconds then quickly if I
I would like to consult this model
if we are not going to generate quickly with
insert the model yes we're going to
insert a new model
we are going through Bogota this project that I am going to
use is the project the same project
that I was telling you this to authorize me
have the pgje and prediction enabled
here I will be united
and I will call bogotá well
and what I need only to load
a model that I need that is that
I need the data from where I'm going to
estimate if with what joke of where I'm going to
I will take this information out of
cloud storage continues so where
encounter klaus thorax notice that here
I have my project I have the option
to go to cloud storage
here I am entering I have different
baquets because inside close toral the
information is stored in baquets and so
what important are we going to use in it
bortolotti test and we go to this file
of text that is called languages ​​if
notice the information that I am
loading that is part of the example is a
recipe I'm telling you this is in
Spanish
this is in english this is in french
generic text if collected and relieved
of internet if only 406 lines per
so the prediction is very elementary
of what we are still doing but
if this file were larger by
course that information that we are going to
to be able to provide feedback at all times is
much more accurate let's test if
works
well then how do we do this
we have to tell him what he was going
is that information
so it would be this tac sandwich file
tac tac tac tac in the basket
look
now if we did it right the genre
of the students
lan wide and txt s is the address of
where I have to carry the load of
the information so that the
model notice that here is telling me
what is there but you are going to insert a model
then list more permission to do it
then there we already gave it was a
control yes so that this can be
execute this takes a few seconds is
after a few seconds it goes away it looks for the
information to klaus thorax of that
file and it starts loading the model
once the model is loaded it
start training the network and it takes about
seconds more between when we have the
model ready to consult if that is
you have to have a little patience that
depends on connectivity and depends on
course the servers that are on
another side receiving and training this
model yes good here we already have the
resolution took 22 thousand milliseconds more
or less and here you are already training
reads with 200 ok
this way now let's check
read quickly I will list here the
models let's check some the
Mexico models for example without
problems while training this
it's true that we're going and we're going to
ask some little things these things
what are we going to ask?
do in python yes very simple but let's
take a few seconds or I'll show you
a complete application of the book of
visits or an example where we're going to
do from the application to the
prediction and skin for now only
we are in the explorer and good here
I have the models if they are ready
bogotá mexico and mx if we are going to consult
well let's tell the mx that is the one
We are going to use
we are going to say that we are going to predict
then number of projects name of the
model that I want to consult and text of
input which you have to evaluate for
determine if what I'm writing
is in English in French or Spanish
if we always do the same
we can write whatever they want this goes
to depend on the accuracy of this going to
depend of course on the amount of
lines that we have
for in the file not good there I gave it
consult that model notice that it came out
200 ok says the hello answer my
name is very complex is in Spanish what
who is writing in Spanish why
because the score that he brings out as you
they see that good is 0 in English in
French and 1 in Spanish already determined that
what I am writing is in spanish
we can repeat this now
with something in English
ok I could be wrong to also have
syntax errors of course this
everything depends on the text file
because from there the
network training that is so so
the return was that it is written in
English well now we have the
resolution this in the explorer let's
start using that model from
python and make the guestbook but
that comes in minutes josecito or in
minute so stay and connected
attentive because now let's check
have an application we are going to do
queries also to the costed model
to determine the suffering of the
people
for how things are coming in the
social network is very slow very slow it seems
that people are waking up late in
Saturday and we are working from
early but our friends in the
Very slow social networks
designer developers
developers on the roof the camera
It is on the roof but good they asked there
I am in a group I would like to know
where is it I'm going to get off before
I'm going down here with the groups
talk because live voice over
Of course, your voice is live there
will determine where the camera is
you can do already we were talking and
let's see in what state is each
group and if they cheer up if voices are encouraged
milestone make another challenge challenge
let's go to football ajn today I have a routine
more sporting base so let's
see challenge nick say here in
how many push-ups let's say we can do
on the floor so we have many things
to play with you
Let's see if we wake up a little with that
intrinsic training not to do
exercise is evident exactly so we
we take a few seconds
we continue heating engines we continue
enjoying this alina drink
technology that we live here in bogotá and
we come back with much more voice developer
2013 Bogota edition we are back
the google technology that I like the most
it's android because it's basically based
focused and connected with all the others
google technologies like that pain link
like the game the plus as is google
maps and how to implement it in
Android is very easy thanks to all the
documentation that has google in the
The penya game platform is
great for space and
availability that it offers to
developers and then android let's say
which is one of the most
used around the world that my
favorite humor technology is google
streetview
I think it helps a lot when
people
are cited to a place
to arrive exactly but before
get to the place you can visit the city
as a technology augmented reality
favorite glue google maps allows you
easily identify together generate
roads and be able to couple the developments
that do not emit favorite wave of google
google maps and the descriptive part
because it allows me to see different places
of the world from your house
the canyon of colorado the non-application
the maximums appear
the group there the bussiness
we go more or less to 20% of the back end
because we are learning python to the
crazy and I think there's no in the group
we are all simply very good at what
what are we doing and joining forces
here to finish fast today I spoke with
Guillermo Gómez I am from the group of 7 are
40 percent but we have
well we're still in this nursery
probos 2013 bogota edition here we are
enjoying together with all the groups by
all this adrenaline course
technological all this this innovation to
favor of regional SMEs all
applications continue to be refined as
we were watching we were talking
with you there are connected of course
all Latin America if we see some
parts of the technological scenario
we were presenting prediction and
We ask quickly how to use the
pencil from the explorer console
We were also analyzing the approach
social so you can of course
chat with us live yes for
course live you can join the
community developers and of course
find all the news all the
events that are happening in this
book but voice 2003 Bogota edition in
liverpool bus dot with google.com well
that we remind you that you can join
you can visit the portal of course and
join the developer community
and of course also from
google inc developers in the
events so check the events of
the prospe also because it is very
important and you will find each of
our alive and do not miss today
great final because we choose the
representing the referent if the
winner of Bogota from Colombia who goes
supposed to represent this region
not missing that that already comes the
winner who is going to be who is going to be
someone is going to be for paco knows something that
as you saw let's say how it comes but in
this moment is still a decision
by taking all the equipment have good
opportunity your successes
but we can ask our friends
who think out there that the social network
for supporting your favorite group by giving
a +1 on your website so it's very
important you can also vote
you can join us but now follow
follow me that we will see to see in what
state are the development groups
as they were during the night
because they have spent programming refining
each of the applications now I
I'm going to go to the end here to see the
company I come to this group look
already has its well prepared here said
well I came the rest of the
developers are still tuning
some of the points came with
here we are going to come to group number
404 we're going to ask him why I
they were saying look it seems to me that
there is one of the groups that you are sure
of something so we're going to ask
come come with me talk to me here
As Andrew sees it, the next winner of the
level
without a doubt want it is the winner
I take the opportunity to give like one
more in our group to be able to win and
we have put the entire file
last night we were finishing the program
what we lack what we want is
present something already
that you can see something that works
how our apps tell you in
Android are the only ones that we are
developing that in an application for
who can see it on the afternoon of
today what a barbarian it is to carry
flags that are the only thing that are
developing a native application
Android, do not come, come, come, come
come for guaranteed to see we are going to
respond live because look, said
andrew nothing but we are the only one here
they turn into a green problem you
we answer better money
perfect and then it is not what are not the
unique
so
you are sure there have been four win
it's very single group number since
happened from bbb we have the native application
android besides the web part
responsible they have a
multiplatform for
perfect that's the last day to
android and it was cut or almost cut the
transmission but it does not matter of barren
earthquake so I know that this one too
has the native and also leave the
Responsive clear for any user
have other technologies, let's say
can of course use the green
limit and
okay
I thought
the one so that it appears with me does not occur in
this album come here of course no no
of course come here to look at me
we have didier here we are populating the
developer booster like you if you
we are also evaluating so what
they are developing in java also or not
they are doing what is called useful and
what model of persistence are
using we are using this now
it's juice from the peña ok and what model
tight
let's be able to the second application in
alive
the idea is to use it we are here
taking note of what we have seen in
our our perfect ok transmission
then let's see how it works
we say that group number 4 is a
solid candidate to earn money
production of 13 is the winner said
well let's see what happens we leave it
there was of course we wish
sit quiet do not get mad at anyone
quiet and I remember a colleague
friend of the community of argentina you
I had many women there in Mexico
I do not know but Pablo for us Pablo
moyano sends a greeting if he is by
there following it too and notice that
has the same style also of hairstyle
that is very interesting to have
I come here player but concentrated
this group if here
in that audience development as
comes super concentrated you too
has a native application us
We are developing a mobile web as
how to shout or in his shouting standing said no
we are supporting the partners or
who are supporting this is very good
are supporting the mario group in the
group because we are talking about a
alliance 89 with 34 for example yes to see
how the application then we have come
working based on the comments of
yesterday we have already made some
improvements on the application ok
we are already solving part of
the repositories ok perfect so either
it comes good we already have the back end
working and moving forward development
technical okey very well to see if you have
to choose someone you want to
interview to see now what are we going to
use the token let's say let's
ask how is the
application to any of the current groups
you prefer that I go
do you want me to ask
we observe group 1 with the group
number 1 if by something particular but be
some of them specifically to duty
and the sites anybody
it seems that here we have an alliance not the 8th and
the 9 against the 1 and the 4 to the 7 look like
we have come to accompany me I'm going
with cooperate as is cooperating as
development goods as it comes comes
appears with me also seems here is
listening to music that music likes
music that keeps me alive so
music keeps you alive here to see
tell me a bit because I want
know a little more about what is
happening here in colombia
vallenato for example
we could listen to see as something
characteristic if I had to choose a
couple of this money but bus to
do a dance to watch
we are going to go choose together with Alejandra
couple let's look let's go to you have to
see that group number 8
in 2008 the group of the couple
perfect we follow then good very
well let's go dance
the dance to see who would prefer
everything of all tell me the group number 3
follow here who of all
people see a return if yes
we hope we wait here
alejandré define who you could get with
to do a typical dance without vallenato
some salsa for genre bar what about me
like I want to see it so keep
he is happy on the 16th the dance is coming
Alexander dance is more I promise you
Alejandro is going to dance with someone from
money but you 2003 like that with camera
spy in hand and with camera in hand for
that you continue to be is here you have to
want to see as alejandro who
we choose to know you can choose any
everything validated is validated so
we will agree look good come here
follow me of course we already have the
partner
we have the couple alejandro with all
everyone all have to dance with
voice is the partner of this developer or bo
2013 let's dance a typical rhythm
Colombian so we already have Alejandro
with whom I have very busy
that is arranged 30 seconds to see that
we liquefy in one thing if not if you do not
We are going to choose
tell me who of the women
choose and the woman will choose the couple
ok who we chose
fast to distant times you are
connected you can choose not to be able to suggest
who do you want me to dance here very fast
Alejandra in the next white who
dance see her she is very busy there
here the group number this we are in the
group number 8 true
accompanying if we could evaluate the
dance and there we see if we review the code
not of course depending on the votes
of the dance comes the revision of
codes I want to see the code I want
see the persistence see how it is
let's invite the group lady
number 8 that is concentrated come by
here Alejandro chose him so that's how they are
They are already good and it seems to me that
knows how to dance well to me it seems that
will be hard for the dancer Jason and
we have to choose because in seconds
we're just going to have to dance a
typical Colombian dance but that
we could dance to search quickly
a vallenato a sauce rim merengue
imagine vallenato we have it more
difficult I need it so I start
look there to see how we do with the
vallenato vallenato I'm going to look for
there of course who is your partner of
book but you to look at the group well
on the other hand you can choose of course
anyone notice that there is also
has my eminem and those in red too
because we have help you can be the
of red too so of course if
To who
there we have it
while paco how that social network comes
weibo all though there are already votes are
voting for him we go team 8
this video equipment plus one
very well very well we have a lot
good photos now surely with this
are going to come several opinions already
we have with whom clear with you
Colombia
ah
jenson we are no longer losing the
control
to see if the evaluation is good after
a pair of sandpaper dances
I promise you that if I promise you
but she chose
it is complicated good is a support choose
software of course if it does not go
to have another another the driver then the
next video
a support a support to see who
syndrome can evaluate the code I am
I'm not going to evaluate the code myself
imagine we can not terms and
conditions and of course of course yes that
let's evaluate the game
it ended here we chose the partner
central mate here perfect there's no
how come companion
also concentrated so we're going to
take a few seconds we will relax
we are going to warm up engines we are going to
look for the musical theme and the
dance on this level but you 2013
Bogota edition let's talk
and we have all contributed a lot
important in the group but I rescue
to our partner who has a lot
knowledge and no help contributed
too much much more thank you
good afternoon no name is july
I'm an arm member of the group
recycle then we take an approximate
75 percent of the project and then
we consider our genius
It has always been our own manager
who was he
who originated the idea good my name
is Ricardo Chiriboga from the group of
agronomy
It seems to me that the one who has given the most
size in the group has been between
designer and the project manager because
they have tried to guide us
about the idea my friend didier is
commissioning the front end part and
the back at that time we already have it in
average by 40 percent
we need to expose the services to the
account for that person of fernando
alonso
Hello my name is Guillermo León
business group
we go more or less to 20% of the back end
because we are learning python as
crazy and I think there's no in the group
we are all simply very good at
what are we doing and joining forces
here to finish fast only with
guillermo gómez I am from group 7 we are
40% but we have the certainty that I
they finish tomorrow and we all have all
contributed many important things in the
group but I rescued our
partner who has a lot of knowledge and
I have not contributed much much more
thank you
good afternoon no name is july
Cesar aso I am part of the recycled group
we carry an approximate 75 percent
of the project and therefore
we consider our genius
it has always been our project manager
who was he
what who originated the idea good my
name is ricardo chiriboga 2003 and let's go
to see the code we forget the dance
why are we going to go into that detail
it does not make sense of course we're going to
see the camera
we keep going
of course ask him colombia wants
let someone dance
and we have an enemy we cut the
microphone to francisco so he does not speak
more and we continue to enjoy of course
we're talking about prediction and
how do we get to the dance good ok are we going to
concentrate we already have a sonia
prepared here is going to dance with the lord
André is here so I'm going
to go down follow me around here comes the
dance challenge and let's see what
code we control because we have the
group number 8 against group number 9
the best dancer that mouths you're going to
choose of course let's vote here
because the applause for the
dancer come the applause for the
dancer masters here in the social network and the
course so there are your comments and
let's see who we're reviewing
the code that's very important that what
let's consider so come
go ahead if you do not think so
come over here let's go to andres is
concentrated came three with me coming
here are 33 steps 4 bars does not pass
nothing, look, this is the dance floor
come they are and also let's see we are going to
see how it is going to get four
compasses of that tremendous vallenato
Colombian
and look how it comes
because if not the two kisses to dance
there are four bars and he taught me the
proximity I feel you get muriel
dance and frame and I do
what are you watching
we are going to have people alone
you find these successes thank you why
André we chose someone to do what
impersonate very quickly
and the second couple quickly whom
we choose who we choose today what
I search
quickly everyone is watching
down because tremendous or I love you
talk demolishing what we are seeing to
I need the vote in the network
social continues he continues to cry out to someone
but let's keep talking let's keep talking
between groups
to the Lord to the Lord the foot is here
and since it is there
come, sir, come here, come, come
for here to see are who we choose
then what is the woman that this one
it quickly replaces the
vallenato very quickly two groups
we have here sir a bow is going very well
here we replace
with this daniela
daniela please don here come daniela
then dance with omar to a sea I see it
I tell you if it does not come with flavor so if
eel comes the volecita vallenato
we have it out there I do not know cinnamon and omar
then the second of the couples that
come to more than startup is the
Colombian vallenato I want to see how
dance here we are going to see them
that
it is not
it has style
very well a strong applause for his veto
for all couples but let's
vote or margin is this that you get what
from this side with your partner you are not
go to each niell to now I would like
know quickly we are going to make a
applause for the couple the number one for
your positive you can vote to iu for your
social to see to see who is the
winner
for ccoo you are concentrated with the
voting on the social network is not true
of course then applause from
developer bush 2013 here in Bogota for
the number one couple as they danced
Andres and sonia to see that applause
and then it would be enough now I think that
has everything all the fans of mexico go
to start voting like this is tremendously
little for digital uses neither
we export digital uses too
but let's ask for the applause here in
The developer voice of the couple number 2
where omar and daniela have danced
also applause for couple number 2
how much
help me little voice help me who to whom
we check and improve but if we do
one last test to see see
the microphone to francisco let's give it
a few seconds to the whole audience
virtual and argentina
Just let's give 1 second to all the
audience that votes and we're going to go to
check the code so that's where we are
let's take a few seconds let's see
how this vote continues we continue
having fun out there I do you for
of course we have the code
presence of a mentor here live
next to us we are going to talk about more
so concentrate and we continue
having fun what am I saying social fun
there is the spy camera look at the area
effect and the spy camera of course
that will be turning around here with
a lot of adrenaline at this level
but when it offers me decision game
size olems
the one that has given the most in the group
It has been between the designer and the project
manager because they have tried to guide us
in us about the idea my friend deals
is taking care of the front part
end and the backend submit them at 40 per
we are missing is to put the services
at point so that that person's
fernando
Hello my name is Guillermo León
group there business
we go more or less to 20% of the back end
because we are learning python as
crazy and I think there are no people in the
group
we are all simply very good at what
what are we doing and joining forces
here to finish fast
guillermo gómez I am from group 7 we are
40% but we have the certainty of a camera
every morning and we all have all contributed
many important things in the group
but I rescue our companion that
he has a lot of knowledge and does not help
contributed too much much more many
Thank you
good afternoon no man is july
Cesar Arzo I am part of the group recycles
pge we take an approximate of 75
percent of the project and then
we consider our genius
It has always been our project manager
who was he
what originated the idea of ​​my name
chiriboga good we continue in this 2013
we are really having a great time as
you come the teams are also
they have fun they really are
going past barbarian here at this level or
2013 tests the promise was to develop
about prediction and skin and we already have
our mentor to talk about
google maps so we're going quickly to
converse the final part of this challenge
I'll tell you quickly and then what
you will be able to find in the repository
of course discovered that we have the
money but it's so I can analyze
line line each of the parts of the
code
we talk about foresight and ask to remind them
also that this is a full play network
complete so that's a point
important we also have a focus
quite flexible and is multiplatform
so let's have those three
features to be able to make use of
this much smarter approach to
our applications also talk
as I am going to show you in the
development that we can train data if
the models are flexible that they want
have once the network with a set of
data but then he could and
permanently feeding and
learn much more than what is
and make much more correct decisions
therefore that is an important point
that we have to highlight prediction and
I'm showing you also a
workflow system a flow let's say
where you can see how the
information supports or out as we were
watching and it's also totally
aligned to the predictive brand mode
land guys which is the default model
one of the default models that
uses a lot in neural networks
about http and https let's say they are the
characteristic questions let's see the
code you cited to see ok
we said that we were going to make a book a
guest book and we will take the
prediction are we going to take the
people's feeling of a model
predicted cost and we will infer
the language with our model looks
I show you quick of the john code
payton this code will be how you can see
I have the reference to the file that is the
language haydee and I will use the model
that we were
using of course forgiveness that is
call mx I have to put the name
project and the pic and because that way
I'm going to authorize the ip and to be able
use prediction and then I have
some models like training the
model check the model predict the
language and return the feeling of
people basically that then the rest
is the construction of the guestbook
yes good of course the code is
commented so you can see it with those
four methods that I have quickly
I can generate the application that I'm going to
do I need to deploy this
application that I already have it here to see
look
let's edit I want to test my book
visits of course I will deploy in
version 3 I am going to show you
quickly we will use social
learning are called social
learning the application in zinc app
notice that here we have it
this is social and learning version 1 and 2
if as you can see we are going to see
that the 2 is not working in this
dam movement there is an error
and we are going to unfold on version 3
there we have it if we do not have good a
error so it's not working let's
to deploy our application here in
version 3 and in this way if the
we have
we display live we see the console
I'm a little hoarse I do not know if you saw that
what a barbarian if here the groups asked
that dance the vuce also quoted so
the ones that are there the salt if you want that
the vuce cited dance we're also going to do
and how good are there votes to dance
so that also to dance for
ccoo the slogan of paco is that dance
to the next one alive so if I
You want of course if you ask for it too
you have it so here you can do
two or that you're there connected what
we are passing the problem of one to
another of course as it comes complicated
in the morning
but look how the vuce cited sensible
The responsability
I'm sweating ok
notice that we already deployed the application
here we have it if you are watching the
console we will see in the online console
yes we already have version 3 I'm going to
give default to use
that that version 3
we are going to use here as you see
social learning and here we have it social
read a little points pop sign the book
of visits and the first thing we have to
to do is to authenticate we were going to take
our our
our our account and that way
is going to realize who is going to go
placing good each of the messages
and for example we can put messages in
English or messages in Spanish or in
French because they are the three elements
that we have the hate you for
example if we are going to send you we signed him
the visiting book and what the
return is that what we are in what
what we are writing is in English
you can see and mark them in red
because he says that and it's a comment
Negative or exact negative
this hotel is very good
we also have to determine what is
as we have for example this hotel
he's very good is saying he's in
Spanish and that the comment is positive
and so we can put a lot of
comments and go using or using
the prediction intelligence for
determine the signature of each of the
comments that we have
tasted was quoted now that very good I
will serve a lot
yesterday the applications much more
interesting ok let's go pay then
we already have our mentor let's talk
from google maps to see what it is about
we present and quickly we continue with
this technological adrenaline here in
Bogota for how we go with our
mentor yes thanks nick here to me
left can very much like
accompany us not very happy thanks for
the invitation forward then if
you want to talk about some maps already
we have your presentation
to the public because the truth is more like my
experience because I am a developer
about 8 years ago I left and
Well, I'm already involved with the subject of
google apps about a year ago
year then then I want is like
count as the ease that then that
have these apps for one to learn and
adopt them then let's say that then today
I will speak as my experience with
google maps and what I identified is
what is a is a free service that
google offers and that lends an amount
of very striking functionalities for
the people we develop
location-based applications
so then the kindness that has
is that it is multiplatform from my point
of sight is to say that I can
develop something for the web and I do not have
than to throw back code because if it
you've gone back to making lines of
code to develop it for mobile if
I can not reuse this code too
is multilanguage, that is, if I am php
payton
in javascript all that I can adopt
and integrates them very easily
for the pgje of maps with my
applications whether mobile or web is a
free service obviously
according to the rules by restrictions
that we put for example then it is
free while it's free to
the end users
also because I have been able to use
Various functionalities of
of this as for example the latitude and
length that is the basic one that tells me
let's say the cardinal points where I
I find the other points of
georeferencing geocoding
reverse seems to me something supremely
striking because that's what makes me
esla
the name of the streets then let's say
In the case of Bogotá, he tells me I'm in the
race 50 with street 144 then
let's say for example the applications that
they are watching last taxi right now and
all that then that's something is very
useful because it already tells me the address
Exactly where I am
very good well thank you very much really
interesting little s the concepts from
from experience let's say that the
let's continue of course they are not going to
accompany throughout the day and that
let's go talking about map six
landmark buses but I want to tell you something
quickly
iván rueda says that baile paco bueno there
seeing them as a fundamental point
also to see what is going to happen at
long of our following following
the next block there's more nick dance and
the code is revised to see what was the
winning couple so keep voting
of course so you have time to
keep voting you are time to
continue commenting for ccoo we are
really very good pass very code and
a lot of fun we have some comment
more yes of course people
thanking the comments on
maps api there that has solved many
problems to people
They want us to concentrate from
now only in the programming and the
no more dancing equipment
I'm sorry it's good that makes me happy
honestly so he treats me very well
well I think that's very good
team number one jumps we're always
talking about dancing
the dance cooperates do not be happy
that the definition comes from the
four by 16:30 by 4:30 pm
now vote so we have a lot to
To travel of course for us is
a pleasure yes to talk with you we are going
to continue reviewing the story with the
groups we have the camera where is the
camera that I do not know there is left in there
so well we keep seeing to see what
occurs between groups and of course
conversing with you enjoying
this live social approach together
you of this technological adrenaline
of this innovation that shows colombia
so let's take a space and
we come back and in an hour
a little voice more or less yes yes already
we're going live at three o'clock
the afternoon of colombia
it seems a lot to me it seems a lot but
well then let's go back
turn to the other side at 12 o'clock
noon we're back with a lot more
technological scenarios traversing each
one of the groups and much more
Much more
2013 developers
But not me
It seems to me that the one who has given the most
size in the group has been between
designer and the project manager because
they have tried to guide us